* Plätschern *
Wie eine Frau
sich trotz ihres Andersseins
einen festen Platz
in der Gesellschaft erkämpft hat -
davon erzählt dieser Film.
Olga Jutzeler, 81, Wirtin im Gasthof
Rössli in Näfels, ist kleinwüchsig.
In ihrer Kindheit und Jugend
wurde sie oft gehänselt,
aber sie liess sich
nicht unterkriegen.
* Handorgelmusik "Happy Birthday " *
(Alle) # Happy Birthday to you.
* Vereinzelte Stimmen *
# Happy Birthday to you!
* Jubel *
* Juchzer *
* Melodiöse Ländlermusik,
Stimmengewirr *
* Rattern *
* Melodiöse Ländlermusik,
Stimmengewirr *
(Frau) Ich bin fröhlich,
weil ich als junger Mensch
nicht so fröhlich sein konnte.
Da dachte ich: "Nein,
so kannst du nicht weitermachen!"
"Da wirst du wahnsinnig."
Deshalb habe ich mich
zum Fröhlich-sein umgestimmt.
Das Leben ist einfach viel schöner,
wenn man fröhlich
anstatt traurig ist.
* Ein Mann lacht. *
Wow!
- Gut, nicht?
Ich wusste gar nicht,
dass ich so schön bin.
Hoi!
Guten Morgen! Hoi!
Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Oh, vielen Dank! Du bist ein Schatz!
An Olgi fasziniert mich
ihre unbekümmerte Herzlichkeit.
Für mich als Schwerenöter
ist das auf eine Art ansteckend.
Ich finde das fantastisch.
Diese kleine Person ...
Wegen ihrer Grösse
eckte sie im Dorf oft genug an.
Sie wurde gehänselt etc.
... dass sie mit beiden Beinen
im Leben steht.
Oh!
# Ta-ra, ra-ra.
Wow!
Gottfried Stutz, kann keiner tanzen?
* Lüpfige Ländlermusik *
# Pa, pi, pa-pa.
Jetzt dann.
* Summen *
* Lachen *
Oh!
* Lüpfige Ländlermusik *
Für die Katholiken ist Näfels
mit seiner barocken Kirche
und dem Kloster Mariaburg
so etwas wie der Hauptort
ihres Glaubens im Kanton Glarus,
der ansonsten
mehrheitlich reformiert ist.
In der Nähe des Klosters,
im historischen Dorfteil,
steht das Restaurant Rössli,
wo Olga seit über 60 Jahren wirtet.
* Melodiöse Akkordeonmusik *
Olga kommt am 7. Juli 1937 zur Welt.
Sie ist das erste Kind
des Ehepaars Jutzeler.
Nach Olga bekommt das Paar
noch sechs Buben.
Es ist nicht sofort klar,
dass Olga kleinwüchsig ist.
Meine Mutter sagte, als Baby sei ich
wie die anderen gewesen, dachte sie.
Vielleicht täuschte sie sich,
weil ich das erste Kind war.
Wenn sie schon eines gehabt hätte,
dann ...
Einen Bruder,
der normal gross gewesen wäre ...
Dann hätte sie es
vielleicht eher gemerkt.
Das ist schon wahr, oder?
Sie ist mit mir nach Zürich
ins Kinderspital gegangen.
Dort fanden sie heraus,
dass ich kleinwüchsig bin.
* Zarte Gitarrenklänge *
Es handelt sich um Achondroplasie,
die häufigste Form
des genetisch bedingten Kleinwuchses.
Achondroplasie entsteht
häufiger durch Neumutationen
als durch Vererbung.
Auch in Olgas Familie ist bislang
kein Fall von Kleinwuchs bekannt.
Ich sagte immer, ich möchte nie mehr
im Alter zwischen zehn und 20 sein.
Das war die schlimmste Zeit.
Hatte mich etwas beschäftigt,
bin ich zum Vater gegangen.
"Meite, was hast du?" Er nannte mich
nie Olga, sondern Meite.
Ich sagte, es hätte mich
wieder einer Zwerg genannt.
Da war ich in der sechsten Klasse.
Er sagte: "Olgi,
das begreife ich nicht!"
"Du nimmst deine Brüder -
Peter und Bruno."
"Die sind viel stärker
als diese Halunken."
"Du musst auf die losgehen!"
"Ich sage dir eines:
Du musst die Knaben zwischen ..."
Jeweils ab Oktober
mussten wir Holzböden tragen.
"Du musst den Knaben
eines zwischen die Beine hauen!"
Die Mädchen
trugen alle lange Haare und Zöpfe.
"Die Mädchen musst du
an den Zöpfen zu Boden reissen."
"Du wirst sehen, dann bessert es."
"Bessert es nicht, sagst du es mir
und ich komme in die Schule."
* Das Garagentor knattert. *
* Dynamische Gitarrenklänge *
* Schwungvolle Musik *
Es geht nach Rapperswil,
wo Olgas Grosseltern gelebt haben,
wo sie als Kind
oft die Ferien verbracht hat
und wo die Boutique ist,
in der sie ihre Kleider kauft.
Was bedeutet dir das Auto?
Mobil zu sein?
Kannst du dir vorstellen, dass ...
... nicht mehr mobil zu sein?
- Ja.
Nein, beinahe nicht.
Ich kann nicht mehr weit laufen
und bin wirklich froh,
dass ich mit dem Auto gehen kann.
Bis jetzt zumindest.
Bei der letzten Kontrolle hiess es,
wenn ich so weiterfahren würde,
könne ich noch lange weiterfahren.
Ich sagte: "Ah, ja?
Dann bin ich froh."
Schau, jetzt fahre ich
schon wieder 104 km/h.
Hier darf man nur 100 km/h fahren.
Kleider ab Stange kaufen
und anziehen, das kann Olga nicht.
Wie bei Achondroplasie typisch,
sind ihre Beine und Arme
im Vergleich zum normal grossen
Oberkörper stark verkürzt.
Die Kleider müssen deshalb
stets abgeändert werden.
Ich brauche immer etwas rotes,
gelbes, grünes oder weisses,
weisst du. Ja.
Mode bedeutet dir ziemlich viel.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich wollte ja Schneiderin werden.
Weil ich klein war,
haben sie mich nicht genommen.
(Verkäuferin) Wie du möchtest.
Ich habe gefragt, warum ich
keine Stelle erhalten habe.
Da hiess es, eine habe gesagt,
sie wolle doch niemanden, der zum
Mass nehmen einen Schemel brauche.
Das hat mir also wehgetan.
Das muss ich sagen.
Ich dachte: "Gottfried Stutz, bin
ich denn ein Mensch dritter Klasse?"
Olga lernt im Rössli
bei der Mutter das Wirten,
macht später auch das Wirtepatent.
Die Mutter
kann die Hilfe gut brauchen,
denn der Vater ist
an Multipler Sklerose erkrankt.
* Scheppern *
* Dumpfe,
langgezogene Akkordeonklänge *
* Heitere,
schneller werdende Akkordeonklänge *
Im Rössli gibt es keine
sog. behindertengerechten
baulichen Anpassungen,
nichts ist extra für Olga umgebaut.
Eine Sonderbehandlung
erfährt sie nie.
Von klein auf wird ihr
eingetrichtert, sie müsse lernen,
sich in der Welt der Grossgewachsenen
zu behaupten.
Der beste Witz im letzten halben
Jahr ist von Erni.
Ein Mann sagte zum Kollegen: "Du
hast doch Bienen. Hast du Honig?"
"Ja, aber du musst warten,
ich habe nur eine Biene."
Ich mag Leute um mich herum.
Ich bin nicht gerne alleine.
Das kann ich nicht.
Ich lasse auch immer das Radio
laufen, wenn ich alleine bin.
* Romantische Instrumentalmusik *
Die Gleichaltrigen
hatten schon einen Freund.
Ich natürlich nicht. War ja klar.
Ich fragte mich, warum ich ...
Ich sagte es meiner Mutter
und sie sagte:
"Das ist so, weil du klein bist."
Meine Mutter
hat mich immer getröstet.
"Olgi,
du bist genau gleich, wie ..."
Sie hat mir immer das gesagt:
"Weisst du, das sind dumme Leute."
Das hat mir dann ...
Sie sagte: "Weisst du,
du bist viel gescheiter."
Das hat mir den Kick gegeben.
Für wen hast du geschwärmt,
als du jung warst?
Oh, für Paul Newman!
Das war ein schöner Mann!
* Schwungvolle Musik, Strassenlärm  *
Im Rössli verliebt sich Olga
in einen Zimmergast.
Grüezi.
Sie ist 18, er 32.
Sie wird schwanger - nicht ungefähr-
lich für die kleinwüchsige Frau.
Die Mutter bringt Olga
nach Zürich ins Universitätsspital.
Ich war sechs Monate dort.
Wurdest du ständig untersucht?
- Ja, jede Woche.
Jede Woche musste ich ...
Und dann musste ich wieder, -
wie heisst das? - in den Hörsaal.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen?
Man kommt mit dem Bett rein.
Man trägt nur ein Nachthemd.
Ich sollte etwas Ähnliches
wie eine Brille anziehen.
Ich fragte,
warum ich das machen sollte.
"Damit man Sie nicht kennt."
Es war mir doch egal,
ob man mich kennt.
War schon klar, dass dein Kind
auch kleinwüchsig ist oder nicht?
Nein, das wussten sie nicht.
Aber ich habe gesagt,
es sei ein Junge und er sei klein.
Den Vater deines Sohnes
hast du nie geheiratet?
Nein. Weisst du warum nicht?
Ich sagte, ich sei schwanger und er
antwortete: "Aber nicht von mir."
Er hat mich richtig böse gemacht.
Und dann mussten wir,
stell dir vor ...
Äh, Ding ... Wie sagt man?
Für den Vaterschaftstest
mussten wir nach Zürich.
Dann haben sie dem Kleinen
Blut genommen.
Der, ähm, äh, Professor
ist dann zu ihm gegangen
und wollte ihm Blut abnehmen.
Er sagte ihm, er sei es -
er ging gleich raus.
Ich habe ihn nie mehr gesehen.
(Originalton, Kurt Zurfluh)
Das ist "Potzmusig" - zum 100. Mal -
mit Nicolas Senn!
Guten Abend!
Olgas Sohn Walter ist mittlerweile 62
und lebt bis heute bei seiner Mutter.
Er versteht, dass sie das Rössli
nicht einfach so aufgeben will.
Sie braucht die Leute um sich herum.
Solange sie kann,
soll sie es machen.
Weil, äh ... Ich kenne sie.
Wenn sie nicht unter die Leute kann,
ist es nicht gut.
Sie machte das ihr Leben lang.
Da kann man nicht einfach sagen,
sie solle endlich aufhören.
Das wäre für sie nicht gut.
Walter, ohne Vater aufgewachsen,
macht sich als junger Mann
dann doch einmal auf die Suche
nach dem unbekannten Vater.
Ich habe ihn einmal gesehen.
Ich war 18 oder 19 Jahre alt.
Ich habe ihn einmal
in Winterthur besucht.
Olgi hat mir nie den Namen gesagt.
Ich habe einmal den Namen
auf Einzahlungsscheinen gesehen.
Ich habe die Adresse rausgeschrieben
und habe ihn einmal besucht.
Wie war das?
Ich wollte ihn einfach mal sehen.
Er war verheiratet
und hatte zwei oder drei Kinder.
Wir haben uns begrüsst, aber ...
Es war nicht sehr herzlich.
Nicht so, wie man es sich vorstellt.
Leidest du darunter, dass du klein
bist oder hast du darunter gelitten
und jetzt nicht mehr?
Ja, es hat schon Dinge gegeben.
Ich wäre gerne Motorrad gefahren.
Schwere Maschinen.
Das konnte ich nicht.
Vielleicht ist es besser,
dass ich es nicht konnte.
Man weiss nicht. Ich kenne mich.
Ich hätte vermutlich ...
Ich wäre vielleicht irgendwo ... Ja.
Und, auch ...
Ich hätte gerne eine Familie gehabt.
Kinder - aber nicht eigene.
Ein Arzt hat mir mal gesagt,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit sei 50:50.
Und, ja. So ...
Aber sonst eigentlich ...
Ich hätte keine kleinwüchsigen
Kinder gewollt. Nein.
Das hätte ich ihnen nicht angetan.
Es gibt vieles,
das man möchte und nicht kann. Ja.
Man muss sich einfach anpassen.
* Lockere Akkordeonklänge *
Natürlich gibt es,
als Olga Mutter wird, Gerede im Dorf.
Eine Frau,
die ledig ein Kind bekommt,
und dazu noch eine Kleinwüchsige.
* Lockere Akkordeonklänge *
Geniessen.
- Mhm.
Und relaxen.
- Ja.
Das Schönste beim Coiffeur
ist das Haarewaschen.  - Ja.
* Lockere Akkordeonklänge *
Heute sorgen nicht mehr die
vermeintlichen Sünden der Mitmenschen
für Gesprächsstoff in Näfels,
sondern der unablässige Verkehr
mitten durch das Dorf.
Über Olga Jutzeler, von ihren
Freunden Olgeli oder Olgi genannt,
tuschelt niemand mehr
hinter ihrem Rücken.
Man begegnet ihr mit Respekt.
Hoi!
- Hoi!
Ich wünsche dir einen schönen Tag.
- Dir auch.
Vielen Dank!
- Tschau.
Tschau, Eva.
- Vielen Dank.
Wie die meisten Menschen
mit Achondroplasie
leidet sie an Rückenproblemen.
Sie muss den Betrieb
im Rössli reduzieren.
Als ich zum zweiten Mal
am Rücken operiert werden musste ...
Er sagte zu mir: "Frau Jutzeler ..."
- Wer ist er?
Der Professor.
Er sagte zu mir: "Frau Jutzeler,
ich muss Ihnen Nein sagen."
"Sie wirten ja."
Er kannte mich.
Er sagte, ich müsse damit aufhören,
das sei viel zu streng für mich
und ich sei in fünf, sechs Jahren
wieder bei ihm.
Ich sagte, ich könne das nicht.
Er fragte, ob ich kochen würde.
Ich bejahte und er sagte,
ich müsse damit aufhören.
Dann sagte ich: "Nun denn."
Dann habe ich ...
Und ich durfte
nicht mehr so viel geöffnet haben.
Dann dachte ich: " Ja, dann ..."
Ich bin nach Hause gegangen
und habe mit den Gästen gesprochen.
Sie sagten, am Mittwoch
und Donnerstag kommen die Vereine.
Dann läuft noch etwas.
Es ist überall weniger geworden.
Und dann ...
Und am Sonntag natürlich.
Seit etwa bald zehn Jahren
mache ich das so.
Ganz aufhören,
also das Rössli schliessen,
das wäre für dich ...
Ja, das wäre ...
Ich weiss es auch nicht.
Es wäre mir zu langweilig.
Dann würde ich ...
Ich kann
nicht ohne Plaudereien sein.
Blättern im Fotoalbum.
Einmal im Jahr
macht Olga Ferien vom Rössli
und bereist
mit ihrer Mutter die Welt.
In Zeiten, in denen Auslandreisen
noch aussergewöhnlich sind,
für Frauen sowieso.
Ein Jahr nachdem der Vater starb,
sagten die Brüder:
"Jetzt fährst du mal
mit Mutter in die Ferien."
"Das gibt es ja nicht."
Da sind wir gegangen.
Und dann hat sie ...
Sie hat natürlich schon ...
Sie sagte: "Ich wusste nicht,
dass das so schön ist."
* Fröhliche Akkordeonmusik *
Wir waren in Kenia, im Senegal.
In Ceylon, auf Mauritius,
auf den Seychellen.
In Thailand, in den USA.
Die Seychellen waren der schönste
Ort, den ich je gesehen habe.
* Blasmusik *
* Gemächliche Marschmusik *
Das Glarnerland feiert, es ist Fahrt.
Der Gedenktag an die gewonnene
Schlacht bei Näfels anno 1388
gegen die Österreicher.
* Gemächliche Marschmusik *
Dann zieht jeweils
die gesamte Glarner Regierung
in einer Prozession
von Glarus nach Näfels.
* Gemächliche Marschmusik *
* Dynamische Blasmusik *
Für Wirtin Olga ist die Fahrt
der wichtigste Tag im Jahr.
Denn direkt vor dem Rössli,
auf dem Fahrtsplatz,
macht die Prozession Halt.
* Feierliches Kirchenlied
"Grosser Gott, wir loben Dich" *
# ... Luft und Meere.
# Sind erfüllt von deinem Ruhm.
Olga bietet für diesen Tag
mehrere Helferinnen und Helfer
für Service und Küche auf.
Am Fahrtstag
herrscht im Rössli Hochbetrieb -
wie in früheren Zeiten
an jedem Wochenende.
... die neuen Wünsche.
Hoi!
- Hoi, überhaupt, ja.
* Stimmengewirr *
Der unter dem Jahr geschlossene Saal
ist an diesem Tag zum Leben erweckt.
Geni, hoi!
- Salü!
Herbi, hoi!
- Olgeli, hoi!
Geht's gut?
- Ja. Danke, ja.
Hoi!
- (lachend) Hoi!
Wie geht es dir?
- Gut.
Wie jedes Jahr.
- Immer, wenn du kommst.
Komm! Da!
Hast du es gewusst?
- Ja, sicher.
Die Originale sterben langsam aus.
Sind die Kinder heute etwas anders,
bekommen sie Ritalin.
Es kann keine Originale mehr geben.
Die Leute, die so sind,
müssen wir pflegen.
Olgeli muss gepflegt werden.
Sie ist ein Riesenschatz.
Olga Jutzeler hätte an ihrem
Schicksal zerbrechen können -
sie ist es nicht.
Vielleicht, weil sie beschlossen hat,
mit Frohsinn
gegen die Traurigkeit anzukämpfen.